WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED ON A
MEETING OF THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE.
BEFORE WE BEGIN I HAVE A COUPLE
OF HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE FIRST OF A
LETTER FROM THE SPEAKER
APPOINTING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
KEVIN MCCARTY AND BILL QUIRK TO
REPLACE. AS ON MEMBERS IAN
CALDERON AND KEVIN MULLIN ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
YEAH.
HE WAS GONNA BE HERE ANYHOW.
ADDITIONALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC STEINORTH IS UNABLE TO
ATTEND AT TODAY'S HEARING I SEE
WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY
WILL WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE
HARPER. HARPER HERE QUIRK HERE
QUIRK HERE AND LOW.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
WEBER HERE WEBER HERE WE HAVE A.
GREAT WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S ONE BILL UP IN
OUR COMMITTEE TODAY THE BILL.
SEC. AND. THE BILL THAT IS UP IN
THE COMMITTEE IS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORKS AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE SIR IF YOU'D
LIKE A PRESENT.
ALRIGHT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WELL YOU WE HAVE.
THE.
.
ELECTION INTEGRITY ADVOCATES
FROM THE VOTING RIGHTS TASK
FORCE THEY HERE TO BETTER.
OKAY.
HE WAS AN EXPERT IN THIS TO GET
STARTED ON TIME. I'M I DON'T
KNOW.
.
RIGHT WELL I I DON'T THINK I
NEED TO SAY VERY MUCH WHY NOT
JUST TURN THIS OVER TO AYE DEAN
LOGAN.
REGISTRAR CLERK OF LA COUNTY
SURE.
OKAY AFTERNOON IT'S GOOD TO BE
BACK UP AGAIN.
IN AN AFTERNOON HEARING FOR THE
MORNING HERE. BUT MY LITTLE
LATER FOR A FLIGHT YOU I'M SURE.
I JUST WANNA I'M BRIEFLY AT KIND
OF RECAP WHERE WE'RE AT WITH
THIS BILL AND AND THINK SIMPLY
MEMBER COURT FOR HIS.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AS YOU
RECALL THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
THAT STEMS FROM DISCUSSION LAST
YEAR ON. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY ON THAT ONE PERCENT MENTAL
TALLY AND THE DESIRE TO MOVE TO
A MORE.
A SCIENTIFICALLY BASED AUDITING
OF POST ELECTION NOT IT'S THAT
ADDRESSES THE OUTCOME OF THE
CONTEST RATHER THAN. JUST OF
THE.
.
EFFICACY OF THE EQUIPMENT THAT'S
USED FOR VOTING SO WHEN WE'RE
HERE BEFORE HAVE WE HAD THE
FIRST VERSION OF THE BILL NOW WE
HAVE A VERSION OF THE BILL THAT
HAS BEEN AMENDED TO INCLUDE.
SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT WE HAVE
WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY ON.
THOSE NOT CONVERSATIONS ARE
ONGOING IT'S A COMPLICATED
ISSUE.
BUT WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS AND AND I THINK THERE'S
STILL A STRONG COMMITMENT TO SEE
THIS MOVE FORWARD AND SO WHY
WE'RE ENCOURAGED. BY WERE RAT
AND.
ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
YEAH รณ I SHOULD SAY THAT I'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH IS A VERY GOOD
ONE. ARE DIRECT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO BALLOT GUIDELINES ON
THAT REPORT. OF MISTER SHOW FOR
IT HAS BEEN.
I HE WAS AMONG THE FOLKS WHO
INTRODUCED ME TO THE IDEA OF A
RISK LEVINE AUDIT.
I HAD THIS SIMPLE BILL LAST YEAR
CONVENTION OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
TASK FORCE AND WAS VERY.
.
WELL IT WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE
AND I FOUND OUT ABOUT WRESTLING
MEAN AUDITS AND.
AND WE'RE HERE NOW TO DISCUSS
THEM JIM DO YOU WANT TO SAY A
FEW WORDS AND JIM VEGAS INERT
QUICKLY THAT'S UNCONFIRMED WITH
THEM.
MAKER IN THE SECOND AREA THAT
INCLUDES THE AMENDMENT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
GREAT THANKS OKAY.
ALRIGHT TO GO AHEAD JIM.
I THINK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER QUIRK
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE.
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THAT YOU
CAME TO THE CONFERENCE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN MISTER
LOGAN.
SO YOU ARE.
MY NAME'S JIM SOPER I AM CO
CHAIR THE VOTING RIGHTS TASK
FORCE.
IN A MEMBER OF A.
GROUP OF TWELVE ELECTION
INTEGRITY ADVOCATES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING THIS BILL.
FEBRUARY.
AND.
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION AND I'M JUST SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF.
BUT PAM SMITH WROTE A LETTER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY
THIRD AND I BELIEVE.
MR LOGAN GOT A COPY OF THAT.
BOB.
AND I'M JUST GOING TO GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THERE WERE
NINE.
TELL ME IF I'M RUNNING TOO LONG
BUT.
.
SOME OF THE COMMENTS.
THIS A RISK WHEN YOU WHAT IT IS
NOT ABOUT VERIFICATION OF
SOFTWARE.
CPO VERIFICATION OF THE RESULTS
THERE IT'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
ARE.
DEFINITION OF RISK WINNING
AUDITS NEEDS TO BE RE WRITTEN.
TO INDICATE AGAIN THAT IT'S
ABOUT THE RESULT WHO'S THE
WINNER THAT'S THE QUESTION NOT
VERIFICATION SOFTWARE QUALITY
CONTROL.
WE NEED A A DEFINITION ABOUT
PULLING AUDITS.
IN THERE IT'S NOT IN THERE.
.
WE NEED DE.
A DEFINITION OF WHAT IS THE
PARTIAL RISK WINNING AUDIT WHICH
IS.
WHAT HAPPENS?
WHEN YOU RUN OUT OF TIME TO DO
THAT THE AUDIT BECAUSE SHE WAS
RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
YOU COULD SAY OKAY WE THINK THIS
IS
SIXTY PERCENT CHAIRS THE RESULTS
ARE RIGHT.
AND YOU RUN WITH THAT.
BUT THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF
DOING THAT IN THIS BILL AT
LEAST.
A AS WE START WHEN PAM WROTE
THE.
THE LETTER.
A.
NOW WITH SELECTION.
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THE AUDIT
IT'S DEFINED SEPARATELY AND IT
NEEDS TO BE UNDERSTOOD TO BE.
PART OF THE AUDIT.
ARTS OF THAT'S.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE.
FOR A.
CHANGED.
AND THERE'S
ARE.
AN ISSUE OF WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO
BE OBSERVABLE.
IN THE SPECIFIC CONTEXT HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BEING ABLE
TO REPLICATE WHAT THE SOFTWARE
DID FOR COMING UP WITH THE
DETERMINATION OF.
WHAT PERCENTAGE ARE WE AT?
WE HAVE DEAD THE SOFT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE REPLICATING COME UP WITH
THE SAME ITSELF THAT IS THE
PUBLIC.
AMENDMENTS ANOTHER LARGER ISSUE
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT GO. FIT INTO
THIS BOUGHT IT'S BEEN A CONCERN.
OF ELECTION INTEGRITY OBSERVERS
FOR A LONG TIME.
IS WERE TOLD TO GO AND OBSERVE
THE COUNTS.
WE CAN SEE THE BALLOTS
WE CAN SEE.
A PAPER AT THIS DISTANCE.
I CANNOT SEE THE MARKINGS.
THAT EVENTUALLY NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED.
ARE IN THE FINAL THING IS THE
SUGGESTION OF.
CREATING A LIST RISK WINNING
AUDIT.
TASK FORCE.
COMPOSED OF OF STAKEHOLDERS.
YOU GO OVER SOME OF THE TRICKY
ISSUES WHICH INCLUDE.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU RUN UP
AGAINST TIME LIMITS?
BECAUSE YOU AT THE END OF THE
CAMPUS PERIOD.
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE BALLOTS
THAT ARE NOT COUNTED OR IF? IT
DID NOT BEEN COUNTED.
BUT THEY'RE VALID BALLOTS.
AND THE LETTER INCLUDES SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR THEIR ART.
THIS WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING THAT. FORCE SET UP TO
TWO.
WORK WITH ALL THAT.
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO GET THIS RESOLVED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT SO I'M NOT QUITE SURE
WHETHER THAT WAS FOR OR AGAINST
BY.
COMING.
OF COMMENTARY YEAH THAT'S FINE
I'M GLAD TO HAVE CHICKENS.
CONTINUING THE INPUT AND WE
WILL WORK ON ALL OF THESE THINGS
IN THE SENATE.
BOB THE SPIRIT OF WHAT HE
DISCUSSES IS CERTAINLY A SPIRIT
THAT I WOULD EMBRACE.
BUT WE WE WERE GOOD NEED TO WORK
OUT A LOT DETAILS.
ANY ADDITIONAL A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR NEUTRALITY OR
OPPOSITION.
FOR WAS DOING EVERYBODY IN ONE
BIG GROUP IT'LL BE FUN.
SHARE BERMAN MEMBERS NICKEL SITE
ON WITH CALIFORNIA COME BECAUSE
FIRST TO ONE OF THINK THE
AUTHORS WILL SEE CO WE CAN WORK
FOR SEVERAL MONTHS ON THIS.
PRODUCT COMMON CAUSES STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF OUR ELAINE CONCEPT
WE THINK THIS IS WHERE THE STATE
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO GO. WE DON'T
THINK WE'RE QUITE THERE YET WITH
THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT.
I'D SAY TO THE THINGS GOING
FORWARD THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
AND HOPE WE CAN READ RESOLUTION
FRAWLEY WILL BE MORE CLARITY ON.
THE USAGE OF BALLOT IMAGES AS
WELL AS THE TIMING ISSUE THOSE
HARD TO ME TO THE TWO LARGER
LOOMING ISSUE.
SO DO YOU THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS WORK AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO COLLABORATE THANK
YOU.
RICHARD TAM OF THE VOTING
RIGHTS TASK FORCE A AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
FOR WORKING WITH US SO.
SO WELL ON THIS BILL AND.
I CONSIDER THIS BILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
WE VERY MUCH ARTS OF. IN SUPPORT
OF A RISK LIMITING AUDIT OF
ELECTIONS WE THINK IT'S VERY.
VERY MUCH NEEDED.
BUT THIS BILL NEEDS A LOT OF
WORK YET A I AM ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE TOTALS THAT ARE USED TO AND
THE TIMING OF WHEN A RISK
LIMITING ORDER ORDER CAN START
BECAUSE.
A ACCORDING TO TALK TO PHILIP
STARK.
ALL THE BALLOTS NEED TO BE
COUNTED.
BUT IN THE REAL WORLD OF THE
VERY LARGE COUNTIES THEY ARE
COUNTING TO THE VERY LAST DAY OF
THE CAMPUS PERIOD.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO COMPROMISE
SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN WHERE
PRACTICALLY ALL THE BALLOTS ARE
COUNTED. AND THE ONES THAT ARE
NOT YET RESOLVED AND COUNTED.
YEAH I CAN BE COUNTED.
FOR THE LOSER COUNTED MOST
CONSERVATIVELY TO NARROW THE
MARGIN.
SO THAT.
OF BUTTON BUT WE CAN'T.
SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA USE THE
TOTALS ON ELECTION NIGHT BECAUSE
THAT.
EXCLUDES A THIRD OF ALL THE
BALLOTS THAT.
YOU KNOW AND SERVE THAT WON'T TO
SO WE ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF RISK LIMITING AUDITS.
THIS BILL WE CONSIDER A WORK IN
PROGRESS.
WE'RE NOT SURE WE CAN SUPPORT IT
THE WAY IT IS RIGHT NOW WE WOULD
RATHER NOT HAVE TO.
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE WE THINK
IT'S MUCH TOO WEAK TO WAITERS
THERE IN NEEDS.
A LOT OF CHANGES YET THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ELECTRIFYING A CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN.
WE'VE NOT YET TAKEN A POSITION
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER ON THIS BILL
BUT WE LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE WORK IN THE SPONSOR. AS
WELL THIS IS WE DO BELIEVE THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT I THINK I I
WOULD.
CURRENTLY ECHO SOME OF THE
CURRENTS THAT CONCERNS BY COMMON
CAUSE IN THE VOTING RIGHTS TASK
FORCE IN REGARDS TO TIMING IN
THE CLARITY OF. A BALLOT IMAGES
AND SOME OF THOSE OTHER ASPECTS
SO I WILL BE WATCHING THIS VERY
CLOSELY AND AND HOPE WE CAN.
HELP WELL.
WHERE POSSIBLE TO KEEP THIS
MOVING FORWARD AND PROVE IT TO
WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE THANK
YOU THANK YOU?
TIFFANY MOCKINGLY HALF OF THE
SECRETARY STATE IN SUPPORT AND
WE LOOK FORWARD THE
CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRING HIM BACK TO COLLEAGUES FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ON THE FLOOR.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MISTER CORBETT YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YEAH SO AGAIN THE SPIRIT OF WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING I VERY MUCH
EMBRACE.
THEM SOME GOOD SUGGESTIONS HERE
ARE ONE OF THE POINTS THE RISK
WOULD MEAN AUDIT IS TO GO BEYOND
WHAT COMES IN ON THAT FIRST
NIGHT. THAT'S ABSOLUTELY PART OF
THE CONVERSATION.
ARM THEN IT'S A MATTER OF
GETTING SOMETHING WHICH IS BOTH
PRACTICAL AND.
AN IMPROVEMENT OVER WHAT WE
HAVE AND I HAVE NO DOUBT WE
FINISHED IT'LL BE AN IMPROVEMENT
OVER WHAT WE HAVE.
.
AND WE'LL JUST SEE HOW CLOSE WE
CAN GET TO THE VERY BEST THING
THAT EVERYBODY CAN SUPPORT FROM.
THE MOMENT I JUST PROMISED WORK
VERY HARD WITH FED CHAIRMAN
OTHERS AND.
COMMON CAUSE AND.
AT CETERA SO WE WILL WORK VERY
HARD AND ALL BILLS YOUR WORK IN
PROGRESS UNTIL THE COVENANT SHOT
AND SEE IF IF IF.
SO AND THAT THE TRUTH YEAH.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH TARA
MISTER QUIRK I ONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR FOR
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
CHALLENGES IN IMPLEMENTING RISK
LIMITING AUDITS HAVING THE
ABILITY TO ON ELECTION RESULTS
IS PARAMOUNT INSTILLING
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS.
I A FULLY UNDERSTAND AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM MANY FOLKS TODAY THAT
OTHER STILL SOME ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING WORKED ON THE ME TO SAY.
THAT THIS IS A REMARKABLY.
IT KINDA TECHNICAL ISSUE AND I
THINK THERE'S NO BETTER AUTHOR
FOR THEN.
MISTER QUIRK.
SO I THINK IF YOU WERE IN GOOD
HANDS IN TERMS OF.
GETTING TO THE RIGHT.
SOLUTION AS WE WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THE STICKIER.
ISSUES THAT ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING.
AND I KNOW THAT.
THE AUTHORED SPONSOR WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE PER
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. SO I
WILL BE RECOMMENDING SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN COMMON NUMBER SIX.
OF THE ANALYSIS
I THINK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOST
MODE HAD THE MOST MISTY PASSES
AMENDED BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
HARPER. HARPER AYE QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE LOW.
IS FEELING IT.
OKAY LA WHO I REFUSE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH. WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO THAT'S OUT.
SIX ZERO AND WE WON'T BOTHER
HOLDING IT OPEN BECAUSE
EVERYONE'S HERE FEES I TO BE
HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT WITH THANK YOU.
WITH THAT THE HEARINGS
ADJOURNED